Roland Emmerich's Midway's historical
war movie that has audiences shaking
their heads with plenty of things I just
seemed too insane to be true but
sometimes reality really is stranger
than fiction here are the things at
Midway you won't believe were true this
is actually what happened
most of Midway's characters are based on
real people including nick jonas is
bruno Godot remember that unlikely scene
when the USS Enterprise has raided by
Japanese bombers only to have them all
miss except for one badly damaged about
to crash into the ship guy doe hops into
a nearby dive bomber and starts shooting
only to send the bomber
careening away at the last minute at the
same time the plane he's in takes a
direct hit surely Hollywood drama rice
it's absolutely true guide oh really did
take a running leap into a pilot plane
then opened fire on a Japanese bomber
intent on crashing into the enterprise
just like the movie depicts the Japanese
bomber
really did clip Goydos plane slicing off
the tail and sending it skidding across
the deck too much excitement for him
there is a tad bit of creative license
that was taken in the aftermath of the
real incident
Gaudio extinguish the gasoline fire and
then disappeared he had been afraid he
was going to get reprimanded for leaving
his watch position but instead he was
found taken in front of Admiral Halsey
and promoted on the spot just like the
film shows even the bravest military is
going to fail without reliable weapons
and equipments and that makes it all the
more shocking the Midway suggests the
Pacific fronts was fighting with
torpedoes that didn't exactly work the
film makes several mentions of torpedoes
not being tested or reliable and even
showing one scoring interact heads only
to break apart and sink and like he's
sounding yes true also yes in real life
the mug for Team torpedo was reportedly
pretty much useless with a tendency to
just not explode after colliding with
its target and the military Nuits
sending the torpedoes into combat even
though they had around a fifty percent
failure rate just a few months after
Pearl Harbor that failure rate had
increased to around 80 percent Midway is
a visually stunning movie that puts
audiences right in the cockpit of world
war ii dive bombers it seems insane that
pilots would literally dive through a
rain of fire to try and sink massive
ships but they did
Douglas SBD Dauntless dive bomber was to
play known as slow but deadly they were
flying at a time when aircraft was still
pretty bare-bones and in the mid 1930s
both the Navy and the Marines were
beginning to appreciate the
death-defying practice of dive bombing
is the best way to accurately aim and
they built aircraft suited to the task
the dauntless have things like split
flaps and dive brakes and allowed pilots
to dive at an 80 degree angle at speeds
nearing 300 miles per hour they turn the
tide at Midway
when taking advantage of a sky
momentarily clear of Japanese
counter-attacks commander Clarence
McCluskey led just a handful of five
bombers against a Japanese fleet
mortally damaging three of the four
carriers and around five minutes the
Doolittle Raid is treated as something
as an aside in Midway a daring mission
happening alongside the main action we
see Jimmy Doolittle and his men heading
out to launch some serious retaliation
on Tokyo with no guarantees are there
carrying enough fuel to get them to
safety Aaron Eckhart's de Latour makes
it into Japanese hell China and meets up
with allies happy to see the Americans
who struck a blow to their oppressors
again absolutely true the mission was
reportedly so secret that President
Franklin Roosevelt wasn't even initially
informed about it
the plan was to take off around 300
miles from Japan's Shores births as in
the film they were forced to take off
much earlier the fleet was spotted when
they were 700 miles south and the early
launch may have saved the mission
Japanese commanders near the shore range
of American fighters and weren't
expecting a long-range launch and
weren't ready for it
it's an odd little detail at first
Midway's Admiral Halsey played by Dennis
Quaid complains of a rash that quickly
gets worse palsy is ordered to step down
and head to the hospital even those with
a passing knowledge of World War two
specific theatres have heard of Rear
Admiral William F bull Halsey so what
gives what's he really sidelined by a
rash yes according to the US Naval
Institute it was just one of a handful
of incidents where illness impacted
command that rash was a severe case of
psoriasis and it was so bad it was
interfering with his ability to make
decisions the biggest change the movie
made was making a symptom of shingles
which is contagious maybe making his
absence seem more justifiable to an
audience wouldn't want to put other
people at risk on the battlefield after
all when audiences sealer you
says Yorktown after the Battle of Coral
Sea she's in a dismal state she's in
drydock gaping holes in the deck with
crews that are dwarfed by the sheer size
of the damage that trying to fix but in
the film she's back on the water and
sailing to save the day just hours
afterwards and likely yes but also true
according to the u.s. Navy the Yorktown
returned to Pearl Harbor with an open
hole leaking oil and sporting enough
damage that it was estimated it would be
90 days before she was operational again
a 551 pound bomb had sliced through the
deck and detonated 50 feet into the ship
her hull was cracked
elevators non-functional and she had
left ten miles of oil and fuel in her
wake
when she returned to Pearl Harbor plans
to Midway were already in the way
Admiral Nimitz gave them three days to
get the Yorktown back in the water and
they did it around 1,400 workers labored
for 72 hours straight on repairs that
were so intensive the island was
subjected to a series of blackouts to
funnel electricity to the repair docks
in Midway American planes have a crucial
advantage time chaos and confusion
stemming from an armaments change over
by the Japanese military and that's
happened according to the Smithsonian
the Japanese air fleet was originally
equipped with torpedoes geared for
fighting American carriers voice armor
aw - Ichi Nagumo gave the orders to have
everything we equipped for an attack on
Midway and that meant swapping torpedoes
for bombs the switch was in mid
completion when they got word American
ships have been spotted by Scouts and
suddenly that meant they needed to swap
back two torpedoes again what followed
was more than chaos Japanese aircrafts
were slow to get into the air and
ordnance was left scattered across the
decks of the carrier's all that's
ordnance was highly explosive and that
had fuel to the fire American dive
bombers started dropping check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you